This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the very unprofessional podcast whereby we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology today is an exciting episode because it's our fourth installment of our let's get friendly series where i bring on a special guest someone who's a friend of of the show just to talk through, you know, their experiences in their 20s, what they've been, what they've learned so far, big changes and transitions before and after moments, strength, weaknesses, goals, all of the above. And today I'm bringing on a very special guest. One of our co-writers, actually, he helps out with heaps of my episodes. And I draw a lot of inspiration from
him. He's an amazing friend. So, yeah, we're welcoming Jack today. I hope you guys enjoy the episode. to everyone this is jack hey guys and gals and gal's yeah come on none of that in here
I'm a bit nervous audience this is actually this is my first podcast it's interesting being on one because I listen to them a lot and so just navigating this new territory I just listen to a lot of podcasts
yeah yeah really culture if anyone listening yeah see see and this is what I'm nervous about I'm nervous about me me saying things that are going to be held against me. And it's all out in the public. Everyone can hear it. But yeah, no, that's me.
I listen to podcasts. Oh, yeah. That's the whole identity. I can believe out anything that makes me sound like arrogant, but I don't think I'll have to. No, no. Yeah, yeah. No, be candid.
I'll be brutal. This is going to be like one of those really intense interviews that they do on like the New York Times. Yeah, oh, sounds good. Ask the tough questions. Yeah. Oh, I don't even know if we have any of those. If I can do an Oprah interview.
Hang on. Hang on. Yeah. You're good? I'm good. I'm still warming up to it. I'm still wanting up to it. Your podcast, your podcast virginity is, you know, it's a hard time.
Yeah, no, no. It's been to be there anymore. No, no, you make a fair point. You make a fair point. So, no, but thank you, thank you for making this special for me. Oh, you're welcome. Yeah, I'm looking forward to it. Yeah, I'll be gentle, I promise.
Also, if you hear Ari in the background, she's making me dinner. That's my househouse friend of the show. Sounds good. She's cooking up the storm. So, that was a bit of a segue. He just had a bit of a yarn. But I want to say, thanks for coming on the show. Thanks for having me.
Yeah, as one of my guests, I feel like we've been friends for a while, like a long time. Yeah, yeah, ages. Ages. All four years, I guess, now. Yeah, oh, my God. Which is weird. Yeah, that's actually, you know, I was thinking of the other day, we've known each other. Well, I've known you my entire adult life.
True, true. Sorry, I was just taking a sip of my wine. For people listening audibly, which is everyone, I'm a big walker when I talk. So I'm walking around with a glass and wine in my room. Oh, you're doing your stroll, getting a step-s-up, Jeff. Exactly, exactly. But, no, that's interesting, right? because I guess I met you right before you turned 17.
18, babe. 18, yeah, when you were 17. Yeah. Turning it, yeah. Hang on. I still remember the first time I met you, actually. Oh, yeah. Have I told you this story?
I think so, because I remember the first time I met you, but you go first. Oh, let's see what our interpretations are. I'll say the first time I met you was like second day of B&G orientation. Yeah, yeah. And I was with one of my friends and we sat down. at a table with you and one of your friends. Yes. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Who I also knew very well. Yeah. But sat down and I remember I was like, the person who was sitting next to me, messaged me and was like, wow, they're really cute. And I messaged about being like, which one? Which was like really funny.
Love it, love it. Yeah. And then I don't know where we went from there. We just became thinking. Oh, and then I remember the first. bonding moment where I was like, we're going to be buddies, was we went for like a really long walk. Yeah, yeah. Like all around the A&U campus and it was very chilling.
We did a lot of those, hey, yeah. Yeah, we did. No, no, that's, I like that. That's funny. No, because mine, I think, I think it's good that we agree that the first time we saw each other was at the table. But no, my first impression of you, I remember sitting down when it was you, Allie, and then Davey sitting next to me. and I just remember like sitting down for one of those random activities not really knowing what to expect and then you guys started talking to us and you were so like engaging and interesting I just remember
being very like you started talking you you're blonde at the time I remember and you just started kind of talking and talking about yourself and I just remember you sounded very interesting but also you're very interested in what everyone else had to say it was really cool so and you're were talking about you said one of the first things you said i think was um you mentioned you were studying russian and i was like that is that is cool that is unique um yeah yeah so i did study russian i was the why was a good russian i was the lous russian shooter ever yeah i would never go to any of my chutes because it was all men yeah right kind of like and i just remember just being like and they were like we should do a study group yeah yeah right well so
All men in the Russian cohort. That's bizarre. Yeah. And there was this one lady, but she was a mature-age student. And I just remember this really funny. My Russian tutor, hilarious. She was really funny. But she was definitely, like, very communist.
Like, all of that. Like, and I just remember one time we saw these people doing yoga. And she was like, oh, looking out the window, we saw these people doing yoga. And she was like, oh, look, it's like indigenous people dancing. And we were like, no, no, no, no, that's yoga. Like, they're doing yoga. Yeah, I mean, it sounds funny because it almost sounds like she, I don't know, I don't know what her background is, but she, she was studying Russian. Oh, her background. Oh, she's a tutor. Okay. Yeah. Okay. She's really her background's Russian.
Like, all of that. Like, and I just remember one time we saw these people doing yoga. And she was like, oh, looking out the window, we saw these people doing yoga. And she was like, oh, look, it's like indigenous people dancing. And we were like, no, no, no, no, that's yoga. Like, they're doing yoga. Yeah, I mean, sounds funny because it almost sounds like she, I don't know, I don't know what her background is, but she, she was studying Russian. Oh, her background. Oh, she's a tutor. Okay. Yeah. Okay. She's really her background's Russian.
No shit. We'd hope. We'd hope. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's, um, that's interesting. She'd always put like, um, Lenin in all of her, like, examples. Like, we'd be doing, like, intense grammar. but all of the questions would involve Lennon. And her thing she would always say is, like, Lenin says to study studies, she'd be like, Lenin is it, it's child, it's child. Right, right. Conjugate this sentence, you know,
Mother Russia will rule the world. Yeah. Well, that's nice. So that's how we met. Yes, yeah. Yeah, I guess that also explains how you're kind of connected to the show because we've kept up our friendship for many, many years. Yeah, we've done well.
We've done really well. We actually have. Yeah, bloody earth. It's a really fun memories. Oh, let me, let me think. Let me think. There's a lot. There's definitely a lot.
I mean, just recently I've been enjoying the walks we've been going on during lockdown. Gem and I've been going up on a few walks through nature. And it's always fun. I think, I don't know. I'll sound very random and a bit tokenistic here. But it's very fun kind of adventuring around in the nature. It is. Yeah.
And what did we find? We went on a walk this weekend. I think we had our biggest hall of fight. Because basically what we do is we go off the beaten path. Yeah, you know, we're individuals, aren't we? We don't go down the path that everyone else goes down, which is we run with the ruse. Yeah, we were just about to say that. We run with the ruse.
We disturbed them. We just trash Mount Ains. No, we don't. No, exactly. No, exactly. But we went for a walk this weekend. Do you want to tell them what we found, our magical spot? Oh, yeah, okay, no, this was fantastic.
So Gemma just decides to take this kind of detail. We're heading down the mountain, and I think you just decide to veer off left randomly. But we stumbled across this little flatland area, so it was kind of like a mountain, but it was almost this plan that kind of extended out from it. And it was really cool because there was this bonfire in the middle, surrounded by logs. it kind of felt like we we entered someone's, you know, camping spot. Yeah.
It was really nice, yeah. It was really nice. And the boulder, I'm like shocked. We found this like, I don't know, like, I don't know. This is just like amazing to me because it's like a concept that's like very like, you know, those books used to read when you were a kid of like kids like adventuring and they'd find like hidden treasure. Yeah, yeah.
Or like they'd find something they weren't meant to find. And I felt like we had that moment because we spotted this like bold. And I think you noticed there was like, you're like, there's something still going to be up. Yeah, yeah. And we realized we could move the boulder and we open up and then underneath it was like a goon bag, like a shovel, sausages. No, it was funny. No, it's like, it was very weird. I don't know why anyone would ever do this, but they, they seem to have dig the hole in their camping spot with a little spade.
Or like they'd find something they weren't meant to find. And I felt like we had that moment because we spotted this like bold. And I think you noticed there was like, you're like, there's something still going to be up. Yeah, yeah. And we realized we could move the boulder and we open up and then underneath it was like a goon bag, like a shovel, sausages. No, it was funny. No, I mean, like, it was very weird. I don't know why anyone would ever do this, but they, they seem to have dig the hole in their camping spot with a little spade.
And they put goon and cooked sausages in there. And it was all mixing around in the dirt. So I don't understand. maybe they were trying to hide the garbage um yeah maybe i i can't understand why anyone would return there take the dirt dirty sausages out and get cracking with the goon again you know i didn't even think about that actually yeah because the goon bag was like full yeah yeah no they hadn't made a dent yeah and then we were like we were like we pinned it on the map so we'll have to go back there i still remember how to get there and like then we found this like really cool like dugout like camp
thing. Yeah, yeah. And we were like, oh, we make, like, this is where, like, the guy sleeps. Like, when he comes up here, like, this is where he sleeps after retiring from his, from his, like, bonfire. And then we found, like, the tire. And we, yeah, it was really, it was great. Yeah, no, we're piecing together, like, little clues of a wider narrative.
And we were creating little characters out of these clues, which was, um, I think, sounds pretty dorky, but it was fun. What were their names again? Oh, Bevan and Devin, I think. Bevan, yeah, Bevan and Devin. Yeah, those two. Oh, God, classic. It was like Brokeback Mountain, but in Mountaine.
Broke back Mount A Cancelain. A Canberra love story. Yeah, literally, a Canberra love story. That was, that was a good memory. We did find. And then we had a little meditation as well. Yeah, yeah, no, that was nice. That was, actually, it was not, yeah, no, so Gem's, I think you've been getting you to meditation recently, haven't you?
Yeah. Is this a new thing? Yeah, I think it's a new thing. It's like, I guess we'll talk about it later. We can talk about it now. I just find it like, I think lockdown's very stressful and like I was finding it hard to like stay present. You know, so it's like I do like three of these a night and they're so good. The app is called Smiling Mind.
If anyone wants to download it, it's free. Yeah. And I was like, Jack, we should do one like in the middle of nature, no one around us. We should do like a listening one. Yeah. And just like see how we feel. See what we feel. And did you feel anything?
Yeah, I mean, because usually my experience with meditation, I never really feel. feel much. This is really quite lovely though. I'll give it a little spook for any potential meditation meditators out there. But it's it was really nice. The whole practice of the meditation was being aware of what you're hearing. And for those who don't know, meditation, at least the one this was all that awareness of all that awareness to what you're feeling, to what you're thinking, to what you're hearing, smelling. And we're kind of halfway at the mountain and there was really strong wind coming through. And at the same time, you felt the wind kind of splash across your face and trickle your
hair. You could hear all the leaves kind of get pulled in the same direction that you were being thrown. Yeah. So it was, I'll sound like a very basic white boy here, but it felt very kind of at one with some of the trees and nature. Yeah. I mean, that sounds weird, yeah. No, it doesn't.
It doesn't. It was, I had the exact same feeling. I felt like the wind was like tickling me. It was like really, I was like trying not to giggle because I was like, the sounds are so present. Yeah, yeah. It's really lovely. And I think it was like listening to your conversations as well. It was like the most beautiful experience.
I would really recommend it. Our conversations. Yeah. Of course. No, all the voices in my head, Jack. Like. Yeah, no, it's hard having dialogue with you. It's like a, yeah.
Yeah, it's like four people speaking. One of my fondest memories actually was, obviously the pure imagination moment. Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes. That was pretty cool. We promised never to tell the story, but just for us. I feel like we should now that we brought it up. It's not going to sound as good when we explain it because it feel like...
It's just... Okay, okay. It's your podcast. Yeah, yeah. Sorry, guys. We're teasing them. But we used to spend so much time in your first year room. Oh, my God. Fondon.
Yeah, yeah. And you had that modeling job handing out. Lint Chocolates. Oh, fantastic. Yeah, that's right. You came and visited, didn't you? No, no, I had, yeah, so I had this modeling job through a modeling agency. And, you know, they gave me a pretty glorious job of dressing up as a link chef
chocolatier, just like you see in the advertisements, and standing in the aisles of coals and woollies and handing out samples of chocolates. What that meant was that when they didn't all get used, I was able to take them home, which meant that I had about, it would have been something like 200 limp balls in my room for about a month after. It was so good. And I'd act like a bit of a big dog and, you know, hand them out to people. I mean, maybe it was a bit patronising back then. I don't know. No, it wasn't patronising. I just remember how I'd see you throw a lint ball at me. And it just got to the point where we had so many yeah because i was getting sick of eating them because there were so many so i was like
chocolatier, just like you see in the advertisements, and standing in the aisles of coals and woollies and handing out samples of chocolates. What that meant was that when they didn't all get used, I was able to take them home, which meant that I had about, it would have been something like 200 limp balls in my room for about a month after. It was so good. And I'd act like a bit of a big dog and, you know, hand them out to people. I mean, maybe it was a bit patronising back then. I don't know. No, wasn't patronising. I just remember how I'd see you throw a lint ball at me. And it just got to the point where we had so many yeah because i was getting sick of eating them because there were so many so i was like
let me just let me spread the love little everyone can have a lymph all so when you were done with your bounty you decided to share it yeah no no no i clearly i'm very i'm very selfless no it was really nice no no but um no i speak speaking of chocolates memory that i've of you jem in first year and even in second year you would always have a little sweet straw oh yeah so So it would be over at your house, your apartment, after going for a run or just studying down, I would always come up and they'd usually be a bit of like an hour or two hour, call off period where we'd hang out. And you just crack up in the sweets.
Have a little chocolate. It was delicious. Oh, yeah, I remember that snack drawer. That snack drawer was, like, you know how they say, like, in America, like, the freshman 15? Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was my freshman 15. Yeah. It was like always, oh, my God, it was the best.
I'd always wanted one. Oh, it's great. Yeah. Yeah, no, no. That's the thing about it. It's like, it was really fun in first, you're first moving away because you can realize you can do anything your parents didn't want you to do. Like, you get ice cream for breakfast and get lollies whenever you wanted.
Yeah. Yeah. Anyway. And you have your own money? Yeah. True, true. With freedom comes great responsibility. I don't know if that's the quote.
Yeah. No, no, no. with yeah great great power to being adult comes great responsibility yeah and i don't think we were very responsible i remember like oh i have so many this is like kind of like a trip down memory like how we've developed into our 20s now like some of those like those silly experiences that we have yeah yeah kind of tape it off but oh my god i just remember my diet was so bad and i said i remember i remember i spent my scholarship money on tickets to europe when i was like manic one day oh true true the snap trip to Amsterdam.
Oh my God, that was silly, but it was fun, fun, fun. I just remember what we used to... Yeah, spontaneous. It was, you know, you shouldn't probably do that again. I remember being on like a China Airlines flight. Being like, am I going to die? I also just have so many fun memories of us watching Louis Thoreau in your room and I would come back from church.
That was a church girl. Yeah, yeah, no, no, absolutely. No, I remember one night we, I know we'd often be hanging out and then we'd hang each other on to get some, go for a little Maccas run. And I remember one night we came back with a bunch of Maccas, sat down with a pillow in the middle and then clicked play on Louis Thoreau. Great talk to the time. Yeah. I know. So, Jack, that was our baby selves.
That was when we first met. I feel like we've come a long way since then. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. What are you up to now? Well, at the moment, let's see. I mean, how do I describe my life? What am I up to now?
Job-wise, I'm working for a government relations firm as an analyst, which is fun. I am finishing off my degree at A&U here, and next year I'm moving across to Sydney to live with you. Yeah, we're going to be together. Yeah, I'm keen, I'm keen. It's going to be good. You've sold it really well, actually. I'm excited. Oh, Sydney summer.
This is, yeah, I mean, have I told you my theory before? It's not really a theory. I'm just really excited for it because half the nation's been the lockdown. Canberra, Sydney, Melbourne. Everyone in Sydney is going to be coming out of lockdown around the summer. The beaches will be open. The bars will be open. And it's just going to be an awesome time because I think everyone's got this pent-up,
social, extroverted energy, or at least the ones who are extroverts. and it's just keen to have a fun time. So we'll have a good time, yeah. We're going to have such a good time. Are you scared? Like, I don't know about you, but I've been super scared of what's going to happen after lockdown.
Like, am I going to become, like, you know, like very introverted? Because I feel like that's what's happened to me at the time. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no, that's interesting. I don't know. I don't think I don't think I'm scared of becoming an introvert. I think I'm scared of all the,
normal responsibility coming back in a way it's like it's like at least at least social life has hit a bit of a pause and so it's a really good time to take some time for yourself but but then when when it comes back you know there's there's events and things that keep you busy um and i think you can get a miss a bit of me time so actually yeah so i think it'd be the same as you i think i'm i'm scared i'll be i'll at least want to be more introverted than i have to be yeah and i feel like we're both extroverts. So I think it's like kind of scary when you go away from the norm of how you've normally like lived your life. Yeah. I've like, like I've adapted so much to being alone that now like the idea of being around people is like quite frightening. So I feel like, yeah, we're going to have
to, the Sydney experience is going to be a whirlwind. Yeah, no, for sure. No, because you do really adapt. Like, I don't know, at least I've found your whole kind of mentality changes around life a little bit. It's not a bad thing. No. It can be. What have you been doing in lockdown? You've been doing heaps of writing as well, which has been very fun for me because I get to read it. Yeah, yeah, well, one of my degree course this year is creative writing. And so I've been doing a bit of creative writing, which has been super, duper fun. It was like, I've just kind of gone back into it because at the start of last year, I started doing a bit of screenwriting because, because, you know, it's a bit of fun.
And then, yeah, and then I picked up this creative writing course for this semester and have just been really enjoying it. And then I've also been doing a lot of article writing too, which has been also very, very fun. Yeah. And thank you for reading them and giving me feedback. No, you've done a great job, I feel like, because you wrote like basically, well, helped contribute to like a whole screenplay last year or like a mini series, basically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was fun. It was a really good time. It was a really good time. Do you want to plug it on the show? What's it called? Oh, sure. Well, it's actually, that's the thing. I can't really plug it because there's nothing out there.
But me and mate last year through, and sorry, actually, end of last year started this year, threw together a few episodes for, it was the idea we had was it was going to be a little mini web series called Shousemates. And I'm going to sound more like a bit of a basic white boy here because I've written a screenplay about uni kids just doing uni things. and so very relatable you know um and so yeah i bet it was just a real i don't know it was the first time really stepped into creativity at all um and i've just absolutely loved it um but it was really interesting because i found i don't know i've given i've been doing a lot more creative things across the last year it's almost like a found little version of my childhood self um your inner child that's a huge psychology concept your inner child is it is it psychology i thought
always like pseudo spiritual. I think it's like new age psychology. It's like I think it's a huge thing with like psychotherapy and like new age spirituality of like tapping into your inner child. But it is like a dialogue that sometimes happens when you use dialectical emotional theory or behavioral theory. So it's like what you want to do is start a dialogue with therapist or someone trusted where you just talk about things and it's about like accepting the things that I guess
a lot of people's psychological situation. come out of stuff that happened to them in childhood. Right, okay. I guess it's a way of like communicating that, and by communicating it, you get back in touch with your inner child and what hurt them and like kind of accepting them. So it's kind of like...
It sounds... Sorry, you go. No, no, you go ahead. I was just going to ask, is it kind of seen through like a trauma or suffering lens, at least? Or is it a lot wider than that? No, that's actually a really good question. I haven't actually thought about that.
I think it's more of like a deprivation lens and like a caregiving lens of like, what didn't you receive? Like getting back in touch with like basic intuition and instincts as well. And I think that's exactly what you're describing. It's like you've learned how to like be creative. And I think creativity is so much associated with having fun. And it's about play.
Yeah. Okay. Especially some of the other things you're doing. Like, oh, Jeff, I love you so much. I just think that you've flourished so much. I've had one glass of wine. No, me too. I'm there with you.
Like, you've just flourished so much into more of your, because you always were creative, always, you always have been in many ways. And I think that you've really flourished into that recently because you've tapped into your intuition and what feels good. And for you, it's like you've produced so many cool things this last year. Yeah, no, thank you. That's very kind. Yeah, but like a psychologist would argue that you've kind of shed the boundaries of what
you thought you wanted to be, you know, when we first entered uni. Yeah, absolutely. You were really set on being a politician. Yeah. And I still think you'd be excellent at that. But, like, you would be amazing. And you had this upbringing of growing up in north, west, what, north beaches, northern beaches. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, Sydney. Yeah. Yeah, Sydney boys school. It was like, there's a lot of structure around that and you've been able to break out of it. So, like, what do you think your process? Because I just remember, like, when I would always be mad at, you would always be
manifesting these political aspirations and now you're pursuing such a more creative path of acting journalism so what do you think kind of allowed you to tap into that can you notice like a point where that became more present in your life yeah no no that's really interesting um i i guess to touch on the point of like how we've changed since since first year because uh do you remember when like it was like two or three weeks ago we're reading the journal entries from our first year selves Yeah. But yeah, I was, I was astounded by how different I was to the point where, you know, I thought I was a bit of a douche. Maybe I still am and we'll think I am in 10 years.
But, yeah, I think, but no, but no, I guess back to the question. I think the biggest thing for me was, I think it was kind of happening towards the end of last year. I went through a bit of a breakup and I was quite upset with life. in general and quite depressed. It's a bit of a morbid entry into the creative world, but it was, for me, it was like, I was feeling quite bad on a daily basis. And the saving grace for me, the kind of thought that I really touched myself to in that time was that if I can write about how I'm feeling, why I'm feeling it,
and I can give a very honest exposition of my inner world right now, even though it sucks, then that kind of gives up this part of my life a bit of meaning. And so it was, I kind of started doing free form, like just random stream of consciousness. It was called Morning Pages, its little technique from that another podcaster enjoys. Tim Ferriss? Is it Tim Ferriss? That's it. I know, I know, sorry. But the technique was you wake up in the morning and you just free form, right for about something like 10 minutes and you just get every single thing in your brain out. And then when you did that, you usually wanted to write a lot more.
Yeah. And I don't know, it just, it provided me a heaps of comfort. And now I started to, over time, develop a little bit of a passion for that form of expression. And that extended into, you know, me wanting to write a bit of a screenplay, do a bit of acting. And I guess, journalism as well. And to kind of express something to bigger than myself through that. Wow. Anyway, hope to ramble.
I don't ramble too much. That's like, I didn't even know that about you. That's like, I didn't know that you were doing that. Maybe you told me and I just wasn't listening. I don't think I told many people. I don't think it really told many people that. Yeah. Well, first you're on the show.
我不太会闲扯。就像，关于你我甚至都不知道这一点。就像，我不知道你当时在做那个。也许你告诉过我，而我只是没在听。我觉得我没跟很多人说过。我觉得我真的没跟很多人提过那个。是的。好吧，首先你上了这个节目。
That's not really incredible, but I feel like that's such a good thing. I think also like where you were saying like you came from a point of pain, like all great artists kind of have pain. You know, no one, even happy stories have a. a deeper meaning or have some kind of contrast to them that is painful to do a suffering. So I feel like it actually probably was the perfect time for you. I remember we tried to give painting a go. Yeah, yeah. But that was around the time I was getting into creative things.
这其实并不是多么不可思议，但我觉得这是一件非常好的事。我觉得就像你刚才说的，你来自一个痛苦的起点，所有伟大的艺术家其实都带有痛苦。你知道，没有人，哪怕是快乐的故事，也有一个更深层的意义，或者带有一种与痛苦相伴的、关乎苦难的对比。所以我觉得，这实际上可能对你来说是完美的时机。我记得我们曾尝试过画画。对，对。但那是大约在我开始接触创意事物的时候。
Yeah. And I think you suggested, should we do some painting? Yeah. That was hilarious. No, because you sat across with me and you kind of sat there and just made this beautiful, like, landscape piece, all from memory, ocean, you know, sun. shore it was this lovely little beach um it wasn't even a beach it was like a shoreline um and then i just did little scribbles and it ended up looking like a preschool preschool art um
对。而且我觉得是你提议的，我们要不要画点画？对。太搞笑了吧。不，因为你坐在我对面，你就坐在那儿，凭着记忆画出了这么一幅美丽的风景画，有海洋，你知道的，有太阳。海岸，那是一个可爱的小海滩，嗯，甚至算不上是海滩，就像是一条海岸线——然后我呢，就随便乱涂了几笔，结果看起来就像幼儿园、幼儿园小朋友画的艺术品一样——
not not not exaggerating right it looked terrible i'm just gonna say i love you so much jack and you i want to make dearest friends but it was a piece of shit it was yeah yeah it literally it was like i think it was like it was a triangle it just didn't make it i yeah it just didn't make sense but you tapped into what, here's the thing, though, this is the lesson, you tapped into what was your creative method or, oh, Ab and your, or, I don't know what it's called. Yeah. Your discipline of creativity. I'm sure the word will come to me.
真的一点都没夸张，对吧？看起来太糟糕了。我只想说，杰克，我太爱你啦，你是我想结交的最亲密的朋友，但这真的是一坨狗屎，确实，确实。字面意义上讲，它就像是一个……我觉得它就像是一个三角形，反正它根本说不通，我……对，它就是说不通。但你触及到了——关键在于，这就是经验教训——你触及到了你自己的创作方法，或者，哦，阿布，还有你的，或者，我不知道这叫什么。对。你的创作纪律。我相信我一会儿就会想起来这个词。
No. But it's funny you mentioned the journal entries because I think we're both huge journalists. And I was going to say, we were, so the other night for the audience, we were, I don't know why we were doing this. We're on FaceTime with Meg, friend of the show. Yeah. And a good friend of the show, actually. And we were, we somehow ended up reading our journal entries from like when we were 18. Yeah.
没有。但你提到日记片段挺有意思的，因为我觉得我们俩都是狂热的写日记的人。我本来想说，我们当时——所以前天晚上，当着听众的面，我们在——我不知道为什么我们在做这个。我们正在用FaceTime和梅格通话，节目的好朋友。对。其实也是节目的好朋友。然后我们——不知怎么的，最后读起了我们大约18岁时写的日记。对。
And it is really insane to see how much you have grown as a person because I think back then you were really focused on, I hope you don't mind me saying this, but like having the life, like being in a relationship, having a good job, being physically fit. And I'm not saying you don't care about all those things. things now. But I think now the metrics of how you weigh your success as an individual, how you deem your worth, is more to do with things that are individually satisfying and tap into, like we've been saying, like that free-flowing kind of creative spirit. Whereas some of the, I remember both of our journal entries were pretty embarrassing.
看到自己作为一个人成长了多少，真的挺疯狂的，因为我觉得那时候你真的很专注于——希望你别介意我这么说——比如过上那种生活，比如谈恋爱，找一份好工作，保持身体健康。我不是说你现在不在乎这些。但我现在觉得，你衡量自己作为个体的成功、定义自身价值的标准，更多地与那些能够带来个人满足感、并且像我们一直所说的那样，触及那种自由流动的创作精神的事物有关。然而，我记得我们俩当时的日记都挺尴尬的。
Let's be honest. Like, some of the ones I read you with. No, that's very, that's very, that's very, yeah, that's a really nice, nice way to put it. Yeah. But no, I mean, even yours is. well. They were both very different. I think you've, I think you've kept the same expressive part of yourself really alive from then. But it was just such a different time, wasn't it? Yeah, it was. It's funny to see how we've, it was really, I think, I think we were both found it very profound. Yeah. And I would so recommend, like that technique, I'm, Tim Ferriss is, firstly, Tim Ferriss is excellent advice for the bedroom. Like, I'm.
说实话。比如，我跟你读过的一些……不，这真的、真的、真的——对，这是一个非常棒、非常好的表达方式。对。但是，不，我是说，连你的也是。它们俩非常不同。我觉得你——我觉得你从那时起就把自己身上那种极具表现力的部分完好地保留到了现在。但那真是一个完全不同的时期，对吧？对，确实是。看到我们如何变成这样挺有意思的，真的，我觉得——我觉得我们俩都觉得这很有深意。对。而且我非常推荐，那种技巧——我，蒂姆·费里斯——首先，蒂姆·费里斯对卧室（注：此处可能为口误或俚语）有着极好的建议。就像，我。
I'm remembering you're telling me about that thing. I actually think that that's really good advice. Like, that's an incredible technique, not to steal his idea, but like in terms of talking about psychology, like just to go back to your point. Like the idea of journaling all of your feelings,
我记起来你跟我说过那件事了。其实我觉得那个建议真的很好。就像，这是一个了不起的技巧，不是要窃取他的想法，但在讨论心理学方面——就顺着你刚才的话说。比如把你的所有感受都写成日记的想法，
everything that's in your head, it is almost a form of meditation itself. Did you find that, that it was meditative or? Yeah, absolutely. No, absolutely.
你脑海中的一切，这本身几乎就是一种冥想的形式。你有没有这种感觉，觉得它具有冥想性，还是？对，绝对有。不，绝对有。
I think the way he puts it is you, you let the monkey brain out for like, 10 solid minutes. And I think when he says to the monkey brain, he's articulating the kind of messy, fast-paced energy of a stressed mind. And it's kind of like the constant anxieties and worries and just thoughts.
我想他是这么形容的：你把内心的“猴子大脑”放出来，持续大概10分钟。我觉得他说的“猴子大脑”，是在表达一种由压力产生的大脑中那种混乱、快节奏的能量。这就好比是不断出现的焦虑、担忧，还有各种杂乱的思绪。
And so I don't know, I found at least when you kind of let those floodgates open, everything is kind of out there on a page. So you're provided with a lot more clarity for the rest of the day. It was cool. And you kept- So I guess it was meditative. Yeah.
所以，我不知道，至少我发现当你把这些闸门打开时，所有的东西都呈现在纸上了。所以你在接下来的整天里会获得更多的清晰感。这挺酷的。而且你保持了——所以我想这确实具有冥想性。对。
Yeah, yeah, I've got it all. I've got it all. Wow. And I don't know if this is like a good question. I'm just really interested just for like our college as friends. But like at what point do you think you kind of turn to being more fiction fiction based than non-fiction? Like I'm guessing at the start you were talking about your feelings,
对，对，我都记下了。我全都有。哇。而且我不知道这算不算是个好问题。我只是出于我们作为老友的身份对此很感兴趣。但是，你觉得在哪个时间点，你开始转向更多地基于虚构创作而不是非虚构创作？我猜一开始你是在谈论自己的感受，
perhaps around the breakup and other things that were going on in your life. When do you feel that it turned to something a bit more expressive or a bit more abstract or not so much based in reality? How do you mean that so? Like, you know, you've been really into the creative writing and also like creative expression. Like, oh, before lockdown. So I, Jack, it was, I don't sure if you're still in the process of auditioning
也许是围绕着分手以及你生活中发生的其他事情。你觉得在什么时候，它变成了一些更具表现力、或者更抽象一点、或者不再那么基于现实的东西？你这话是什么意思？就像，你知道的，你一直对创意写作非常感兴趣，还有像创意表达。哦，在封锁之前。所以，我，杰克，我不——我不确定你是否还在经历试演流程
for acting school. Yes, yeah. Which I fully support, by the way. I want to have a really rich. Yeah, well, I think 99% of active friends are not rich. So you'll be buying me dinner. Oh my God. It's going to be like, we're going to have, dude, we're going to have, dude, we're going to have
为了考戏剧学校。是的，对。顺便说一句，我完全支持这一点。我想拥有一个非常丰富的……对，好吧，我觉得99%的演员朋友都不富有。所以你会请我吃晚饭。哦，天哪。这将是——我们要有——伙计，我们将要——伙计，我们将要
so much creative input next year. Like, just the struggling, like, creative, like, journal, actor and then, like, the wild corporate sellout. Yeah, yeah. Oh, no, it's going to be very interesting. Like, you could write a show about us. In fact, I could write another screenplay about my life. Oh, goodwill hunting-esque.
明年有这么多的创意输出。就像，仅仅是那个苦苦挣扎的、充满创意的、写日记的演员，然后，还有那个疯狂投身企业出卖灵魂的人。对，对。哦，不，这会非常有趣。比如你可以写一部关于我们的剧。事实上，我可以写另一个关于我人生的剧本。哦，有点像《心灵捕手》风格的——
Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah. And then we make it to the Hollywood by, you know, sending around a screenplay and applying for it. I think that's great. I fucking hope I'm your day. No, absolutely. Like I was a friend, but, you know. Yeah.
是的，对，对，对。然后我们通过（你知道的）到处发送剧本和申请，杀入好莱坞。我觉得这太棒了。我他妈希望我是你的一天。不，绝对的。就像我是个朋友，但，你知道的。对。
No, no, no, for sure, for sure. But I think, I think if you'd be a really good person to show, you know, to bring into that world with, I think it'd be cool. You'd have some very cool insight and support. No, yeah, no, the acting school, yeah. So I will be applying for it. But I think a slim chance of getting in, if I get in, which is very slim, I don't, I don't think I'm too keen on it. But I think it's good to keep the options open. Yeah. Why aren't you as keen on it as you previously were?
不，不，不，当然，当然。但我觉得，我觉得如果你是一个很棒的人选，你知道，能被带入那个世界，我觉得会很酷。你会有一些非常酷的见解和支持。不，对，不，那个表演学校，对。所以我会申请。但我认为被录取的几率很小，如果我被录取了——这几率非常小——我其实，我觉得我对此并不是太热心。但我认为保持选择开放是件好事。对。为什么你没有以前那么热心了？
I just, I just don't, I just don't think it's the right thing for me now. I think at the moment with work, like I'm obviously working in politics, there's a certain element of like you'll have your finger on the pulse and you'll have very good access to information through people in certain periods of time. And when you step away from that for a while, it kind of dissipates. And I'm just enjoying the world too much to kind of shut down the opportunity too early. Wow. If that makes sense. Yeah. So what do you think has changed?
我只是，我只是觉得，我只是觉得这现在对我来说不是对的事情。我觉得目前的工作，比如我显然在政治领域工作，有一种元素是你会紧跟时代脉搏，在某些时期通过某些人获得非常好的信息渠道。当你从那退一步一段时间后，这种优势就会消散。我太喜欢这个世界了，不想太早关上这个机会的大门。哇。如果这说得通的话。对。所以你觉得什么改变了？
Because I feel like we were doing, we were practicing intense monologue. Oh, like, I just think you're bloody talented. Like we did this one. I remember we were going through all the monologues that you could possibly audition with. And there was that one that we did. Do you remember what the name was? Yeah. No, it was.
因为我觉得我们当时在做，我们一直在练习激烈的独白。哦，就像，我只是觉得你太有才华了。就像我们做过的这个。我记得我们一直在看所有你可能用来试镜的独白。然后有我们做过的那个。你还记得名字是什么吗？对。不，它是。
I can't remember the name, but I remember how it went. It was pretty intense. Yeah. Yeah. And so I think back then you were really keen on it. Do you think that like, why were you so keen on acting? And back then, do you think it was like something that you felt was unfulfilled and now that you've kind of things have changed? Do you realize that actually there's other stuff that's out there?
我不记得名字了，但我记得它是怎么进行的。相当激烈。对。对。所以我觉得那时候你真的很热心。你觉得——为什么你对表演那么热心？在那个时候，你觉得那是某种你觉得未被满足的东西，而现在事情变了，你意识到其实外面还有别的东西？
Do you think it was acting was such a drastic change or like what do you think it was? Yeah, no, no. I'll give, I'll kind of step back a bit and give a maybe convoluted an answer, but I hope it provides a bit of clarity. For me, for me, it's like the way I've seen my brain kind of work across the last year, particularly around these career ambitions and taking risks, there's kind of two sides that I see myself wrestling with. There's a very idealistic side that gives me a lot of credit. to be successful. So for example, in the acting domain, when I'm kind of standing and looking down the career path,
你觉得表演是一个如此剧烈的改变，还是你觉得是什么？对，不，不。我退一步，给出一个可能有点迂回的回答，但我希望它能提供一点清晰度。对我来说，就像我看到自己的大脑在过去一年里运作的方式，特别是在这些职业野心和冒险方面，我看到自己在与两个方面搏斗。有一个非常理想主义的一面，它给了我很多信任，让我相信自己会成功。所以例如在表演领域，当我站在那里看着这条职业道路时，
my idealistic brain will be like, this is something that makes you very happy when you do it, which is actually quite true and not very idealistic. But it's the idea that if you are in this industry, then you will be very successful and a certain certainty in that. And then a more, I guess, critical or realistic side of the brain, which I guess takes that with the realities that it comes with in that, okay, you think you're going to be very successful. Every person who goes
我理想主义的大脑会觉得，这是当你做这件事时能让你非常快乐的事情，这其实挺真实的，也不是那么理想主义。但它的理念是，如果你在这个行业，那么你将会非常成功，并且其中有一种确定性。然后是我猜更具批判性或更现实的一面，我猜它伴随着随之而来的现实，即，好吧，你觉得自己会非常成功。每一个进入这个行业的人都会成功吗？真正成功的只有百分之一。所以在权衡我希望接下来的生活如何度过，你知道，三年表演学校，然后，你知道，也许，也许得到一些我热爱但收入不稳定的好工作，并后悔没有选择一条更稳定的、我没那么喜欢的职业道路，这就是我没有那么享受的那个。这就是我意识到的事情。哇。对。不，这非常合乎逻辑。这说得通吗？如果有点迂回，请告诉我。不，不，这完全说得通。我觉得作为朋友听到你这样说真的很有趣，觉得，哦，我以前不理解你的大脑是怎么运作的。
into it will be. Only one percent really are. So in terms of weighing up how I want to spend the next, how will my life to look like, you know, three years in acting school and then, you know, maybe maybe getting a few great jobs that I love. But, not having a lot of financial stability and regretting, not taking a more stable career path would be the one I don't enjoy as much. That's a, that's the realization I came to. Wow. Yeah. No, that makes a lot of sense. Does that make sense? Let me let me know if it's a bit convoluted. No, no, it made perfect sense. And I think that like, it's actually really interesting hearing that about you as a friend and being like, oh, I didn't understand that's like
呃，就好像你必须权衡。我想这是我们在20岁时经常面对的事情，就是：你会选择激情之路，还是那条你认为能让自己感到满足但或许并不稳定的路？
how your brain was kind of working. Um, in terms of like, You kind of having to weigh up. And I guess this is something that we deal with a lot in our 20s is like, do you take the road of passion and the one in which you believe you'll feel fulfilled, but perhaps not stable. Yeah, exactly. Everyone listening to this can relate. You know, we all have these aspirations of living in a van or being an artist or being a musician
对， exatamente。每一个听这个的人都能感同身受。你知道，我们都有这些渴望，想住在房车里，或者成为艺术家，或者成为音乐家，
or doing something that's against kind of the stream of life. But then having to handle those practical limitations of, oh, I need to eat. and, you know, how much is this struggle really going to be worth for a few moments of like, not even glory, but of satisfaction? Yeah. So it's kind of like you've done that, it's taken you a few months, I guess, but you've done that equation in your own time. Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
或者做一些逆流而上的事。但随后又必须应对那些现实的局限，比如，哦，我需要吃饭，你知道，为了那些短暂的——甚至算不上荣耀，只是满足感的时刻，这种挣扎真的值得吗？所以这有点像是你已经做过了，虽然花了好几个月，我想，但你在自己的时间里完成了这个方程式。对，对，绝对是。
And I think there's a lot of, yeah, it's interesting as well because when you, when you're weighing it up, I think there's a lot of emphasis on the individual in our culture. and there's a lot like the obsession with personalities and that sort of thing makes you inclined to believe that you know you are the you are the one that will make it and that sort of thing um but i i think yeah i think it's i think it's worth you know at least wrestling with that with some potential realities um yeah would you call it delusional would you call it delusional though because i feel like yeah it's no that's interesting that's interesting i'm I think I would call it slightly delusional, but the weirdest thing about it is that if you don't
而且我认为有很多，是的，这也是有趣的，因为当你权衡时，我觉得在我们的文化中对个人有很强的强调，而且对个性和诸如此类事情的着迷会让你倾向于相信，你知道，你就是那个会成功的人，诸如此类。呃，但我——但我认为，是的，我觉得至少值得带有一些潜在的现实去与它搏斗……是的，你会称之为妄想吗？你会称之为妄想吗？因为我觉得，是的，不，这很有趣，这很有趣。我想我会称之为稍微有点妄想，但其中最奇怪的事情是，如果你没有那个，
have that, I don't think you'll ever be successful in that field. Like you really, you need to have that conviction. Maybe you don't. At least the people, the people I've listened to who, you know, and watch interviews with that have done on that, the underlying thing is there is that conviction. So I think it may be slightly delusional, but it doesn't mean it's. It's a bad thing as long as you're willing to take the potential costs of, you know, not being that successful. God, it makes sense.
我不认为你能在那个领域取得成功。就像你真的，你需要有那种信念。也许你不需要。至少那些我听过他们访谈、看过他们采访的人，潜藏的东西就是那种信念。所以我认为这可能有点妄想，但这并不意味着它是件坏事，只要你愿意承担那些可能不成功的潜在代价。天哪，这说得通。
Yeah, we really are PPE. We just did a phone. Yeah. It is. It is. Yeah. He's discouraged. So I have to ask because I feel like we're both kind of at this stage where we have this like two roads diverge situation.
对，我们真的是PPE专业（哲学、政治与经济）出来的。我们刚刚打了个电话。对。确实。确实。对。他泄气了。所以我得问问，因为我觉得我们俩都处于这种状态，面临着这种“分叉路口”的情况。
Yes. Yep. Where it's like we've got the corporate option. the stable option, the career progression, house at 30, marriage at 35 kind of option. And then we both have, I think this is why we really connect as friends, is because then we both have these like very strong creative desires. Yeah. That seem like possibilities.
对。是的。就像我们有公司选项，稳定的选项，职业晋升，30岁买房，35岁结婚的选项。然后我们两个都有，我想这也是我们作为朋友真正能连结的原因，因为我们俩都有这种非常强烈的创作欲望。对。看起来像是可能性的选项。
And I wonder, you know, in 10 years time, regardless, which path do you think you would be happier on? Like, do you think that you would... Yeah, yeah. All things considered, do you think you would be happier as a successful actor? Or do you look happier, you know, regardless of the stuff, the struggle that you've had to go through? Or do you think you're going to be happier as someone who is working in politics, I'm sure, very successful? Have you thought about it?
我想知道，你知道，在10年后的某一天，无论如何，你觉得走哪条路你会更快乐？比如，你觉得你会……对，对。把所有因素考虑在内，你觉得作为一个成功的演员你会更快乐？还是你看起来会更快乐，不管你经历过多少挣扎？或者你觉得作为一个在政治领域工作、我确信会非常成功的人你会更快乐？你想过这个吗？
Yeah, yeah, no, absolutely, absolutely. I think it's like, you're right. When you're stepping out of university and looking at getting what, I guess, the first job in your career is going to be. It can be two parts. I think for me, and I don't know how this resonates with you, because by the way, guys, Jenna is an absolutely incredible painter. And also a really good writer, but you haven't written as much lately as you usually do.
对，对，不，绝对，绝对。我觉得就像，你是对的。当你刚走出大学，看着即将到来的第一份职业工作时，它可以分为两部分。我想对我来说，我不知道这是否能引起你的共鸣，因为顺便说一句，大家，珍娜是一位绝对不可思议的画家。而且也是个非常棒的作家，不过你最近写得没有以前那么多了。
Like, very good writer. Very, very good. And, yeah, at least for me, the, I, because I, that's, I think I started to, the reason I was bearing on acting was because I did see it as a bit of a fork and that, you know, if I didn't get into it now, that I never will. The thing that really did it for me, I really long conversation with my dad about, you know, this and what, what, and weighing on my choices and how it would reflect. And the best thing he sent to it, he said to me was, you know, just because you say,
像个非常优秀的作家。非常，非常优秀。而且，是的，至少对我来说，我之所以一直在考虑表演，是因为我确实把它看作是一个分叉点，你知道，如果我现在不进去，我以后就永远不会了。对我真正起作用的是，我和我爸爸就这个进行了很长的谈话，关于这个和什么，以及权衡我的选择以及它会如何反映。他对我说的最好的一句话是，你知道，仅仅因为你现在说“不”，并不意味着机会永远关闭，这听起来真的很基础，他构架的方式是你可以去过那种你可能也会相当享受的常规职业生活，并在空闲时间做你喜欢的创意事情——
know now it doesn't mean the opportunities close forever which sounds really basic the kind of the way he framed it was that you can go off and have the conventional career that you might also quite enjoy and do the things creatively that you like so you know write act whatever in your free time
比如写作、表演什么的——而且以后总会有机会进一步探索，特别是如果你一直在后台默默积累的话，如果这说得通的话。所以听起来我有点像个卖国贼，但……
and there'll always be opportunities down the line to further explore that particularly if you've been you know building it up in the background, if that makes sense. So I sound a bit like a sellout, but... No, no, I think that... I swear it's true. What do you think?
不，不，我觉得……我发誓这是真的。你觉得呢？
Well, I think that sounds exactly like something your dad would say. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Absolutely something your dad would say. Like, you know, I go to your house and I get, like, tarot card readings from your parents. Yeah. And, like, energy readings. Like, I feel...
嗯，我觉得这听起来太像你爸会说的话了。对，对，对。绝对是你爸会说的话。比如，你知道，我去你家，能从你爸妈那得到塔罗牌占卜。对。还有能量占卜。就像，我觉得……
No, you're right. Well, his exact words were, you know, when you ask... His exact words were when you ask something of the universe, you know, it will provide you an opportunity, many opportunities along your life path, which, you know, which, which I don't usually take at face value, but it was, it was very reassuring. It's what you needed to hear, I think, at that point. Yeah, yeah.
不，你说得对。嗯，他的原话是，你知道，当你向宇宙索求时，你知道，它会在你的人生道路上为你提供一个机会，许多机会，你知道，你知道，我通常不会全盘接受，但这非常令人安心。我想那就是你在那个时刻需要听到的。对，对。
He said what you needed to hear, which is such like, kind of a beautiful thing. Yeah, exactly. Big shout out to Neville and Devils. No, definitely what I needed to hear, not what I think I wanted to hear, which is cool. But, yeah, how do you see the two roads diverging and your play? We've talked about this a bit, I think, actually. Like, we talked about it the other day. And I think I'm kind of at a bit of a, I don't know, I'm a little bit confused.
他说出了你需要听到的东西，这真是一件很美妙的事。对，绝对的。向内维尔和德维尔斯（Neville and Devils）致敬。不，绝对是我需要听到的，而不是我想听到的，这很酷。但是，是的，你是怎么看待这两条路的岔开以及你自己的剧本的？我们其实已经聊过这个了，我想。就像我们前几天聊过的一样。我觉得我有点，我不知道，我有点困惑。
I love having this podcast, but I think it is such a creative outlet. And obviously, I think quite a bit. But it has been the thing where I think I've become quite existential and thinking about, like, the concept of, like, one life and, you know, is, you know, you're going to be dead anyway. perhaps you should really just enjoy it. And it's kind of, do you enjoy the risk and the idea of a big payoff? Do you enjoy the common luxuries? And that's a huge thing I've been, you know this,
我很喜欢做这个播客，但我觉得它真的是一个极好的创意出口。而且显然，我思考得也挺多的。但这确实让我变得相当存在主义，开始思考比如“人只有一生”的概念，你知道，反正你总会死的，也许你真的应该尽情享受它。这有点像，你享受风险和巨大回报的想法吗？你享受常见的奢侈品吗？这是我最近一直在思考的一个大问题，你知道的，
like that I've been kind of thinking about recently is whether to take a creative path. And I think that like what your dad said has been kind of my reasoning as well in the less spiritual way because he's a very spiritually blessed person. And more so I was just kind of thinking like, you know, I never know what opportunity. may come up in the future. And what financial freedom might actually be able to bring me
就像我一直在思考是否要走一条创意之路。我觉得你爸爸说的话也成了我的理由，虽然是以一种不那么精神性的方式，因为他是一个非常充满灵性的人。更多的是我当时在想，你知道，我永远不知道未来会出现什么机会，而财务自由实际上能带给我什么
in terms of realizing dreams of moving to Corrumbin and having my art studio and having my creative studio and being able to bring women and people and elderly people and anyone to come and join me. So it's like, you know, having, I guess money is kind of the... Activates a lot of your future ambitions. And, you know, Jack, like, the guy who played hand solo didn't become an actor to who he's like 40.
在实现搬到柯伦宾（Currumbin）、拥有我的艺术工作室、拥有我的创意工作室的梦想方面，并能够带女性、人们和老年人以及任何人来加入我。所以这就像，你知道，拥有，我猜金钱就是那种……能激活你未来的许多野心。而且，你知道，杰克，那个扮演汉·索罗的人直到40多岁才成为演员。
True, true. You're going to be such a silver fox. Like, I would be worried. Oh, stop it. Yeah, I'm worried about being silver fox. My mom's a hairdresser, and every time I go to Sydney, she'll find, like, one or two grey hairs growing when I'm getting my haircut. God.
真的，真的。你会成为一个那样的银发帅哥。我会担心的。哦，别这样。对，我担心变成银发帅哥。我妈妈是个美发师，每次我去悉尼，她在我理发时都会发现一两根白头发长出来。天哪。
So I don't know if I can support the look. I hope I can. But, yeah. I think that you can. Your mom is an excellent hairdresser as well. I remember last time we went up there, you went up to the app, and I had, like, this two-hour, like, your dad, because. I feel like I'm quite close to your family.
所以我不知道我能不能驾驭这个造型。我希望我能。但是，是的。我觉得你能。你妈妈也是个极好的美发师。我记得上次我们去那儿的时候，你去了那个应用，然后我呆了两个小时左右，就像你爸爸一样，因为我觉得我和你家人挺熟的。
I really love them. No, they love you. Honestly, they speak so highly of you. Like, like kind of on par with Milan, who's been my best friend since preschool. They really like you. Yeah, you hear that, Milan? I'm fucking, you're a territory, bitch. No, they're really, they're just such lovely people.
我真的很喜欢他们。不，他们也喜欢你。说真的，他们对你评价很高。就像——差不多和米兰（Milan）一样高，米兰是我从学前班起最好的朋友。他们真的很喜欢你。对，你听到了吗，米兰？我他妈的，你是领地主，碧池。不，他们真的，他们只是非常可爱的人。
I think very highly of them as well, actually. So hopefully you share this, that you did this show with me, so they can like me more. Yeah, yeah. that. I'll share with my parents. Hey, guys. Hey, mom and dad. Hi. But I remember, like, going up there. They just provided such wide advice and your mom, I was going through a breakup at the time. And your mom gave me, like, the post-breakup haircut, you know, bangs. Yeah. And they look good. They look good as well. Thank you. They're not looking as great as when your mom, yeah, banging.
其实我对他们的评价也很高。所以希望你能分享，你和我一起做了这个节目，这样他们能更喜欢我。对，对。那个。我会分享给我爸妈的。嘿，伙计们。嘿，爸爸妈妈。嗨。但我记得，去那儿的时候。他们提供了如此宽广的建议，还有你妈妈，我当时正经历分手。然后你妈妈给我剪了，就像是分手后的发型，你知道，刘海。对。而且看起来很好。看起来也不错。谢谢。看起来没有你妈妈剪的时候那么棒了，对，刘海。
Yeah. They're not looking as good. That's what they call bangs? Yeah, bangs. Yeah, yeah. I'd be such a guy sometimes. but yeah bangs and I remember yeah anyhow that was an event later that evening yeah yeah they do provide excellent advice and like yeah I think what your dad said is completely real and just something that we all have to consider and a big shout out to people who do choose to take that road less travel and it is like something that we all come across
——不过，齐刘海儿。我有时候真是个直男。但是，对，齐刘海儿，我记得——是的，无论如何，那是那天晚上的一个活动。对，对，他们确实提供了极好的建议，而且，对，我觉得你爸爸说的话完全是实话，这也是我们所有人都必须考虑的事情，并且要向那些真正选择走那条少有人走的路的人致敬，这确实是我们都会遇到的事情，
but in terms of the kind of lifestyle you have now tapping into your creative side what's that kind of one habit that you've picked up that you kind of want to see yourself doing in 10 years? Would you hope that you're still writing and still acting? Or do you see yourself? Yeah, I think I see, I don't really know. I think like as we're talking about earlier, first year, Jack, would have a 10-year kind of trajectory.
但就你目前的生活方式而言，去触及你的创意之侧，那种你想要在10年后的自己身上看到的、你养成的习惯是什么？你希望自己10年后还在写作和演戏吗？还是说你看到了自己……对，我想我看到——我其实也不知道。我觉得就像我们刚才说的，第一年，杰克，会有一个10年左右的轨迹。
But if it's like anything to last, you know, this is a really boring answer, but I've stopped making really long-term plans in life because I realize that what I enjoy and what I'm discovering about myself changes so often that I'm constantly re-learning how to live a happy life. But I think that things that I've learned as a solid, which make me very happy, which I'd want to do in the future, is definitely writing creatively. On my off days, I'll usually have a routine where I'll get up in the morning
但如果要长久的话，这是一个真的很无聊的回答，我已经停止在生活中做非常长期的规划了，因为我意识到我喜欢什么、我对自己有什么发现，这些变化得如此频繁，以至于我不得不不断地重新学习如何过上幸福的生活。但我认为，我已经学到并作为基石的东西，它们让我非常快乐，而且也是我未来想做的事情，绝对是创意写作。在我的休息日，我通常会有一个日常：早上起床，
and get down on the keyboard and I'll do an hour at least. So I hope I'm still doing that because I think it's a really good way to kind of express yourself. And it's a bit of a pressure valve for me. It really releases a lot of energy and thoughts and ideas that I have. Yeah, that would be the one thing. I think that I want to keep consistent, you know, it keep, you know, kind of kind of like when I first started doing it. Keep, keep expressing what I'm thinking and going through the moment. and, you know, turning that into some form of entertaining art.
坐到键盘前，至少写上一个小时。所以我希望我还在那样做，因为我觉得这是表达自我的一种非常好的方式。对我来说，这有点像是一个减压阀。它确实释放了我内心大量的能量、想法和点子。对，这将是唯一的一件事。我觉得我想保持恒定，你知道的，保持——你知道，就像我刚开始做这件事的时候那样。保持，保持表达我此刻的想法和经历，并且，你知道，把这些转化为某种具有娱乐性的艺术。
Yeah. Would you ever write a novel? I've never asked you this. Do you think you could write an upper novel or something like that? Like, what would you write? Yeah. Yeah. No, no, no.
你会写一部小说吗？我从来没问过你这个。你觉得你能写出一本长篇小说或者类似的东西吗？比如，你会写什么？对。对。不，不，不。
That's a really good question. I don't, I think I would love to, but I don't think I have yet this is, this is a kind of, I really haven't tested it, but I don't really think I have the attention span right now. I find that what I, like, you definitely know this, What I enjoy changes every week. And so I would get one. Like the best part of short stories is that you can write it in two days or three days. Nobles, it's like a six-month, 12-month, 18-month journey.
这是一个很好的问题。我不会——我觉得我很想写，但我不认为我目前有——这是一个——我真的还没尝试过，但我真的不觉得自己现在有那么长的注意力跨度。我发现我喜欢的东西——你肯定知道这一点——每周都在变。所以我会得到一个——短篇小说最好的地方在于你可以在两天或三天内写完。而小说呢，这是一个六个月、十二个月、十八个月的旅程。
And I think it's maybe later in life when I settle down and start and start getting a bit more stable with my passions, I can commit to something. Yeah, yeah. If it was. Yeah, yeah. Wait, yeah, if it was, tell me, tell me. No, you go. No, I want to hear if it wasn't. I think I think if it was, I'd love to do like a little like Aldous Huxley kind of utopia.
我想也许是在晚年，当我安定下来，开始对我的热情变得更有规律时，我才能全身心投入到某件事情中去。对，对。如果是的话。对，对。等等，对，如果是的话，告诉我，告诉我。不，你先说。不，我想听听如果不是的话会怎样。我想——我想如果不是的话，我很想写一部类似于奥尔德斯·赫胥黎那种乌托邦式的小说。
He did this, he wrote this book, he's the author of Brave New World, which is the bad utopia, the dystopia. But he did this awesome book called Ireland. And he spent about five years researching all of these different things about spirituality, social psychology, a lot of, it was a lot of Eastern religion and Western science kind of fused. And he wrote this really beautiful utopia based on, you know, what we knew about humanity at the time. That was really cool. What was it like?
他写过这个——他写了这本书，他是《美丽新世界》的作者，那是那个不好的乌托邦，也就是反乌托邦。但他写过一本很棒的书叫《岛》。他花了大约五年的时间研究所有这些关于灵性、社会心理学的东西，其中很多——是东方宗教与西方科学的某种融合。他根据当时我们对人性的了解，写了一个非常美丽的乌托邦。那真的很酷。那是怎样的？
So it was based on an island and there were a few really cool principles of it, which was that all the children belonged to, first of all the population was very small. And all the children... Probably why the utopia worked, you know. Exactly. Yeah. And all the children belonged to, like, every parent sort of thing. So it was, like, kind of collective child-rearing.
所以它是基于一个小岛，那里有几个非常酷的原则，其中之一就是所有的孩子都属于——首先人口非常少。所有的孩子……可能这就是乌托邦能行得通的原因吧，你知道的。正是。对。所有的孩子都属于——某种程度上属于每一位父母。所以这就像是一种集体抚养。
Yeah. And there was a lot of meditation that was emphasized. A lot of... There were a few principles. I read it ages ago, so I forgot it. Very good. Yeah. Yeah, well, it was cool.
对。而且强调了大量的冥想。大量的……有几个原则。我很早以前读过它了，所以记不清了。非常好。对。对，好吧，那很酷。
Yeah. We were talking about Buddha the other day, why he was weirder. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, exactly. I was going to meditate under a tree for two weeks. I know. No, yeah, literally he sat under a tree for two weeks, only to realize, you know, at the end of it,
对。我们前几天还在谈论佛陀，为什么他那么奇怪。对。对，对，正好。我本来想在一棵树下冥想两周。我懂。不，对，字面意思，他在一棵树下坐了两周，结果在最后才意识到，
this is a bit much. I need to chill out and take the middle path. I would just be craving child time. I don't know. Can you get deliver root to your Buddhist tree? Yeah, yeah. No, I think modern Buddha would. Yeah.
这有点太过了。我需要冷静下来，走中间道路。我到时候肯定会渴望有跟孩子在一起的时间。我不知道。你能把外卖送到你的佛陀树下吗？对，对。不，我觉得现代佛陀会的。对。
Yeah. No, I don't want to disparage the modern Buddha for any Buddhist listeners. But we respect. religion here. We definitely, hey, but you know what we need to do next year because I feel like
对。不，我不想为了任何佛教徒听众去贬低现代佛陀。但我们尊重这里的宗教。我们绝对——嘿，但你知道我们明年需要做什么吗？因为我觉得
we could both write novels and they'd be fucking fab. Oh yeah? What do you reckon? Well, I just think we need to just like do some really crazy stuff and just like really pushing
我们俩都可以写小说，而且它们会他妈的棒极了。哦，是吗？你觉得呢？好吧，我只是觉得我们需要去做一些真正疯狂的事情，真正突破我们的界限，拥有狂野的经历。就像我觉得我们明年我们需要去经历，去做出一些——就像你刚才说的那样。我知道你在谈论更多的是乌托邦、反乌托邦和未来的世界。我觉得在我的某些——对，我觉得它更多地不是基于政治和社会学的理想主义，而是更多地——
out of our boundaries and just have like wild experiences. Like I feel like we like next year. We need to just have, just do something like I feel like what you're talking about. Like I know you're talking about more of a utopian, dystopian,
（注：原文中133-136部分说话人思路跳跃，以下为对应翻译）
and future world. I think in my some yeah I think it's more based in not so much political and sociological idealism but it's more yeah
（接上）喜欢写一本优秀的情窦初开/成长的小说——那种既原始又……
love to write like an excellent like coming of age story like something that's like raw and it's yeah yeah how just terrifying life is but also just how like just
对，对，关于生活是多么可怕，但也关于各种经历和人类的体验，我觉得这是创造这些东西的绝佳时机，因为我觉得所有优秀的故事都源于非常真实的地方。
experiences and the human experience and I feel like such like an amazing time to kind of like make those because I feel like all good stories come from a place that's very real yeah no absolutely no I really I really like that idea that's fantastic I really like that well I haven't yeah no no no but like but no no it's a really cool theme though and I think um it definitely be worth like sitting down and talking about it um yeah or like dirt because because I think yeah yeah you go yeah no no you go just living
对，绝对的，不，我真的很喜欢那个想法，太棒了。我真的很喜欢，虽然我还没——不，不，不，但这确实是一个很酷的主题，我觉得……绝对值得坐下来好好谈谈，或者像……因为我觉得，对，对，你先说。不，不，你先说。仅仅是去经历那种贫穷……虽然我们不会穷，我觉得这么说不好，但就像悉尼的年轻人那样——我不知道，也许这是一种陈词滥调，是以前被做烂了的东西，也许我在美化我们未来的生活，但就是拥有所有那些经历。
to her poor well like being like poor we're not going to be poor I feel it's bad to say but like young people in Sydney like I just I don't know maybe that's like a cliche like something that's been done before maybe I'm idealizing our future life but like just having all those experiences
（注：137对应上述贫穷/年轻人的片段）
and I think also you know this very well about me like I'm very obsessed with like capturing your youth and that's why I do like my one second a day that's why I do these podcast episodes just like being able to have something to look back on and relate to and being like, wow, like, you know, my biggest fear is being like 40 with kids and not being able to know, to know, to look back on and reflect on all the experiences
而且我觉得你也非常了解我——我非常痴迷于捕捉我们的青春，这就是为什么我每天做“一秒钟”视频，为什么我做这些播客节目的原因，就是为了能够有一些东西可以回头去看、去产生共鸣，并且觉得：“哇，你知道的，我最大的恐惧就是40岁时有了孩子，却无法回首和反思我所经历的一切。”
that I had. Absolutely. That was so profound. And I just think like messy. Just messy. Yeah, yeah. No, I like that. No, because I think, and I was thinking of doing this for a while, but kind of going back
绝对的。太有深意了。我只是觉得那种杂乱无章——就是杂乱。对，对，不，我喜欢这样。不，因为我觉得——我有一段时间一直在考虑这个，就是回过头去翻看我的日记，看看我的人生所呈现的形状以及我是如何成长的。
through my journal entries and kind of looking at the kind of shape my life has taken and how I've grown. and like by way of catharsis, maybe revisiting those painful moments and capturing that somehow. And so I like your idea of capturing like a messy coming of age use. Yeah. Because I also like, like, I think, you know,
并且通过宣泄的方式，也许重新审视那些痛苦的时刻并以某种方式将其捕捉下来。所以我喜欢你关于捕捉那种杂乱的、成长的青春的想法。对。因为我也觉得——至少在我成长的那些年里，你会看到那些把一切都安排得井井有条的大人们，以及所谓的稳定性。而你会给自己设定非常苛刻的期望。所以我觉得过去几年里出现的那些关于生活可以多么混乱、可怕和令人恐惧的原始艺术形式是最好的。因为它们能给你带来最大的慰藉。
at least my years growing up, you see adults who have it all kind of together and what a stability. And you set really hard expectations on yourself. So I think the kind of raw art forms that have definitely been emerging the past few years about how messed up and scary and terrifying life can be the best. Because they give you the most comfort.
（注：141对应上述原始艺术形式带来慰藉的片段）
Yeah, absolutely. And I think, like, that's actually, it's a good point. And I think that, like, my favorite book, like, A Little Life, does that really well. Maybe that's where I'm getting my inspiration from because I just read it. But it follows these, like, people from the ages of when I was 16 to, like, 40, living, like, in New York, following all these different career paths. and just growing their lives and all the things that happened to them and the conflict and the love and
对，绝对的。而且我觉得，这其实是个很好的观点。我觉得我最喜欢的一本书——《渺小物种》（注：A Little Life，通常译为《小生活》或《渺小物种》）——就把这一点做得非常好。也许这就是我灵感的来源，因为我刚读完它。它讲述了这些人从我16岁到40岁左右的年龄段，在纽约生活，经历各自不同的职业道路，
not just the drama but just like the nuance of human interaction. It's just the most, like, real life is just a bit of a wedding, I think. And that's just like that book, excellent. I'll have to read it. Yeah. I think it's very long, but I think you would really like it at this point in life, actually. I'll give you my copy. No, thank you.
不断成长并经历发生在他们身上的所有事情，包括冲突、爱，不仅仅是戏剧性，还有人际交往的细微差别。这简直是最——真实的生活其实有点像是一场婚礼，我觉得。那本书就超级棒。我得去读读。对。我觉得它很长，但实际上你在这个人生阶段会非常喜欢它。我的那本借给你。不，谢谢。
No, you're right. There's a real beauty. like capturing those little moments. Yeah. And kind of, I don't know, it's really hard to describe, but you kind of, that I, it's almost like where where you kind of touch life, if that makes sense. Yeah, yeah. And it's, you can really feel it.
不，你说得对。捕捉那些小小的瞬间有一种真正的美感。而且，某种程度上——很难形容，但你那种——这几乎就像是你触碰生活的地方，如果这说得通的话。对，对。而且你能真切地感受到它。
Yeah, it's like, it's like, you can really feel it's very granular. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, anyway. No, no, no, you're, you're absolutely right. And I think that like the big part of it, but I love this book is there's no moral. There's no, like, moral of the story. Like, it's not trying to teach you anything. It's not like all those books you have to read in high school
对，就像是——就像你能真切地感受到它是如此具体细腻。对，对。对，无论如何。不，不，不，你完全说得对。而且我觉得很大一部分原因——我喜欢这本书是因为它没有道德说教。它没有——你知道的，故事没有什么深刻寓意。它不像你在高中时必须读的那些书，
where there's like this kind of theme of, you know, redemption or guilt or honesty or bravery. It's just, it's not trying to teach you anything. It's not giving you a moral. Like, I think it's the most adult book I've ever read because it's just like, this is the brutality of life. And it's joyful and it's hard. And it's not trying to force anything on you in terms of an ideology. it's like a reflection and reading it I was just like these characters just make such
里面带有某种救赎、内疚、诚实或勇敢的主题。它不是在试图教给你任何东西。它不给你灌输道德。我觉得这是我读过的最成人化的书，因为它只是在说：这就是生活的残酷。它既充满快乐又无比艰难。它没有试图在意识形态上强加给你任何东西。它就像一面镜子，读完之后我只是觉得这些角色创造了如此——
like she just creates such a beautiful beautiful world that feels so real and yeah I think I've said I like said this to the guy that I'm seeing um the other day I was like oh fuck I forgot what I said oh yeah like I haven't read the final I'm so terrified of an ending because it just is so real like I know that something bad is yeah right oh no I know, and I've never read it. I've read the book so many times, I've never read the last pages. Yeah, yeah. Because it feels like...
她创造了一个如此美丽、真实的世界，以至于——对，我想我跟正在交往的那个男生说过这个——前几天我还在想：“哦，操，我刚才说什么来着？哦对，我还没读完结局，我太害怕看到结局了，因为它太真实了，我知道一定会有不好的事情发生……”哦，不，我懂，而且我从没读过。这本书我读过很多遍，但从来没读过最后几页。对，对。因为感觉……
I love, I love spoiling things, so I'll have to hold myself together after I read it. Oh, I know what happens. I don't want to spoil it, but I just know. Like, it's all leading up to this point, and I'm just like, terrified because it's just so fucking real and so existential, and it's just like too much for me, I think. Yeah, no, it's a figure- either. It is really reassuring seeing those types of things where they, There's no theme or moral lesson.
我喜欢剧透，所以我看完之后得克制一下自己。哦，我知道会发生什么。我不想剧透，但我就是知道。这一切都在向这个节点推进，我只是觉得——太害怕了，因为它他妈的太真实了，太具有存在主义意味了，我觉得这对我来说有点太沉重了。对，不，这并不可怕。看到那种没有任何主题或道德教训的作品，真的挺让人安心的。
It's people trying to reflect their own realities. I think it's been a huge thing that's come up in the TV scene at the moment. Where you have like this, oh, what's the show? Euphoria was a really good example where it's not thematic. It just gives like just very real stories about what people go through. And it has this, I'll never forget it has these amazing introductions to each episode. where the episodes will kind of take a focus on a particular character, but it gives you the kind of character's story and upbringing in background at the start of it.
这是人们试图反映他们自己的现实。我认为这是最近在电视界出现的一个巨大趋势。就像这个，哦，那个节目叫什么来着？《亢奋》就是一个很好的例子，它不是按主题来的。它只是讲述了人们所经历的非常真实的故事。而且它有——我永远不会忘记——它对每一集都有非常精彩的开场，每集会聚焦于某一个特定的角色，但在开头它会为你展现这个角色的故事、成长经历和背景。
So, for example, there's one of the stories focuses on a closet homosexual, and he goes through this background of, you know, him being shamed by his dad for being feminine and making the football team and all this thing. and then you kind of see his story play out in the episode. And you always thought he was a bit of a dick in the previous ones. And it just completely covers his image. Wow. Just flips the narrative.
所以，举个例子，其中一个故事聚焦于一个柜中同性恋者，他经历了这样的背景：你知道的，他因为女性化而遭到父亲的羞辱，加入了橄榄球队，等等诸如此类的事情。然后你就会看到他的故事在这集里展开。而在之前的剧集里，你一直觉得他有点混蛋。这完全颠覆了他的形象。哇，直接反转了叙事。
It's kind of also like way back, which you and Tom recommended to me, where it's just like, this is dirty life. Like, yeah, yeah. That's it. Like, that's it. I don't know. Maybe there's like, maybe someone who studies literature can, like, give us, like, the name for what kind of genre that we're talking about.
这也有点像很久以前，你和汤姆向我推荐的那部，就是那种生活很残酷的感觉。对，对，就是这样。就是这样。我不知道，也许研究文学的人能给我们说出我们正在讨论的是哪种类型的流派。
Like, perhaps that's why we never write a novel, because we don't know enough about literature. But yeah, I feel like there's a name for it that someone leave it in the show. I don't know. Reach out. Leave in the show notes. Yeah. Leave the show notes team.
也许这就是为什么我们永远写不出小说，因为我们对文学了解不够。不过是的，我觉得这应该有个名字，谁知道的话可以留在节目里。我不知道，联系我们吧。留在节目注释里。对，留给节目注释团队。
Yeah. No, definitely. Yeah. We've been recording for almost an hour. Yeah, you're right. So, yeah, before we went on, you said it was going to go fast and it went very fast. I hope it didn't embarrass myself. Because I was very nervous at the start.
对，没错，绝对的。我们已经录了快一个小时了。是的，你说得对。所以，在我们开始之前，你说时间会过得飞快，确实过得非常快。我希望我没有让自己出丑，因为我在开始的时候非常紧张。
And I don't like coming across in a bad way. I think I was being careful about that. I hope I was right. No, dude, this was like literally, I think the best part about good friends is realizing that no matter how long you've been friends, you can still discover something new about someone, and still have incredibly engaging conversations
我不想给人留下不好的印象。我想我当时挺注意这一点的。希望我做对了。不，老朋友，这简直是——我认为好朋友之间最棒的一点就是意识到，不管你们做了多久的朋友，你仍然可以发现关于某人的新东西，并且仍然能够进行极其引人入胜的对话，
that are just, like, really enlightening. And I have to say, I'm like, thank you for having me on. It was, it's a really cool invitation to have a very interesting conversation. And you ask very, very good questions. Um, so am I the next Oprah? Could I be Ellen? Yeah, I think so. I think so. Yeah, if Australia hadn't Oprah, it'd be you. Oh, thanks, babe. Yeah. This is going to be my new. That's going to be my highlight of the week now. Um, but yeah, thank you so much for coming on. You're such a dear friend. So it was, and I think we've been talking about doing this episode for a while. And I'm sure the listeners who
而且真的很有启发性。我必须说，谢谢你邀请我来。这是一个非常酷的邀请，能进行一次非常有趣的对话。你问的问题非常好，非常棒。所以，我是下一个奥普拉吗？我能成为艾伦吗？对，我想是的。我想是的。对，如果澳大利亚有一个奥普拉，那就是你。哦，谢谢宝贝。耶。这将会成为我新的。那将成为我本周的高光时刻。不过，非常感谢你能来。你真的是个亲密的朋友。所以，我想我们已经讨论要做这一集有一段时间了。我确信那些
are still listening, you'll hear from him again. We've got another episode in the work. Oh, true. We barely even talked about it actually, considering how much we've discussed it. But, um, yeah, I'm kind of glad that we didn't touch on it because I feel like it's such an episode in its own right. Yeah, a little sneaky surprise. Yeah, a little sneak. So you'll be hearing more of Jack's voice. Yeah, yeah. Hey, guys.
还在听的听众，你们还会听到他的声音。我们还有另一集正在筹备中。哦，真的吗？其实我们刚才几乎都没怎么谈到它，考虑到我们讨论得那么多。不过，我其实挺高兴我们没有触及这个话题，因为我觉得它本身就是极其精彩的一集。对，一个小小的潜伏惊喜。对，一个小彩蛋。所以你们会听到更多杰克的声音。对，对。嘿，大家好。
I hope you to enjoy it. Hi. But yeah, thank you so much to Jack. One of my co-writers, as I said at the start, who helps me out with so many of these ideas. And we have so many discussions. And he's, you're just such a big inspiration. You really push me to do this. So a real gratitude extending out to you.
希望你们会喜欢。嗨。不过，真的非常感谢杰克。正如我一开始所说的，他是我的联合创作者之一，他帮我想出了这么多点子。我们进行过无数次讨论。而且他——你真的是个巨大的灵感来源。你真的促使我完成了这件事。所以我要向你表达真挚的谢意。
but yeah thanks jackie oh thank you no that's that's really kind and yeah thanks thanks thanks being such an awesome friend and um yeah yeah so you go no you're doing your outro i need i need to stop talking no no i was just i was just gonna say this is it's so good you've committed to this for so long you've the podcast has been amazing and um no i'm i'm i'm I'm often in awe of the things you do constantly. But I don't say that often. Oh, true friends. True friends.
不过，真的谢谢你，杰克。哦，谢谢，不，这真的太客气了。对，谢谢你成为一个这么棒的朋友。嗯，嗯，所以你来——不用，你来做结语，我需要——我需要闭嘴了。不，不，我只是——我只是想说，这真的太棒了，你坚持做这件事这么久，这个播客一直以来都太棒了，而且——不，我——我经常为你一直以来做的事情感到惊叹。但我并不常说出来。哦，真朋友。真朋友。
But thanks to Jack for stroking my ego there. Remember to, well, if you liked the episode, which I hope you flippin did, because it was bloody good. I hope you subscribe to us in Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you're listening right now. Follow us on Instagram. And yeah, I hope you really enjoy the episode. So thanks for listening. Jack. See you. See you guys.
但是感谢杰克在那里拍我的马屁。记住，嗯，如果你喜欢这一集——我希望你他妈的真的很喜欢，因为它他妈的太棒了。我希望你在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 或你现在正在收听的任何地方订阅我们。在 Instagram 上关注我们。是的，希望你真的很享受这一集。谢谢收听。杰克，再见。大家再见。
Love you. Bye. Thank you. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast.
爱你们。拜拜。谢谢。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神韧性、体能和建立心理弹性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》，也就是 TWO，在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。《Look Back At It》播客。
In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
1979年，那对我是个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not have to be played with.
那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你可别想随便惹我。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。这是一档 IHart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。